what we would like to think that we can
predict people's behavior we can't
always do that people behave in
unexpected ways they do things that are
unthinkable and unimaginable and thus
the question becomes how do you
understand that you know how do you
dissect behavior the hulu original
series chance paints the portrait of a
forensic neuropsychiatry who embarks on
his own dark journey we take a closer
look at the new thriller with the help
of a real-life neuropsychologist my name
is dr. Angie Burrell forensic
neuropsychologist essentially focus on
decoding the puzzle of human behavior
quite often we meet people who function
according to societal norms and slowly
over time they deteriorate in some way
where they made choices which are
peculiar or self-destructive Elden
chance is a 55 year old right-handed
neuro psychiatrist
the blade is increasingly aware of a
mental state he finds to be dark and
unstable
and those people are interesting because
their life doesn't follow a path that's
easily predicted and understood everyone
has a story and they got they got to be
where they are going to a host of
factors I spend my days in the company
of those mutilated by life as a clinical
neuropsychologist the areas of the brain
that are of most importance would be the
limbic system and the prefrontal cortex
or the prefrontal lobe the limbic system
regulates human emotion affective memory
our capacity to become angry even
aggressive so for example if we have a
perceived threat that may activate the
limbic system
it's the prefrontal area that perceive
you know this activation and then help
us to determine how we want to proceed
if the prefrontal lobes are not working
properly you can't have a lot of trouble
they could be really a bad situation
since its discharge the patient admits
to both visual and all Factory
hallucinations
we look at ourselves we always have
explanations and rationalizations for
why we don't behave as we should have
people don't always behave rationally
and they're not always responsible do
you really still not see what dangerous
ground this is or is that what you like
about certainly there are a number of
challenges of doing in a forensic
neuropsychology or forensic psychology
sometimes we put ourselves in situations
which which there is some potential risk
of some potential danger you know maybe
that's what makes it a little exciting
as well the unpredictable nature
[Music]